We discussed access control
in the last lesson.
But that was only one kind
of access control called
discretionary access control, or DAC.
That allows you to decide
who you want to share a resource with
when you create the resource and own it.
If you work for a company, or
a defense or intelligence organization,
you don't get to decide how information
that you access can be shared.
The company or the agency will mandate
how various types of information
is accessed by different users.
For this, we're going to develop
a number of mandatory access control,
also called MAC, models.
Once we're done with,
this we're going to revisit the idea of
a trusted computing base, or
a TCB, and explore how we can
evaluate the level of assurance
that is provided by such a TCB.